le pregunto que todavía no existe
certeza cuando va a terminar este conteo
oficial de votos la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales está contabilizando
las actas que vienen de las zonas
rurales del perú y mientras esto sucede
todavía continúan arribando al país los
votos emitidos en el exterior en el
paralelo debemos de señalar que existen
como mil 181 actas que han sido
impugnadas por personeros tanto de keiko
fujimori como de pedro castillo estas
actas han sido derivadas al jurado
nacional de elecciones este organismo va
a decidir a qué candidato le otorga la
validez de estos votos he conversado con
una fuente electoral y éste me ha
informado que en el mejor de los casos
el conteo de oficial de votos podría
extenderse hasta el viernes o sábado de
esta semana